[Music]
hey guys I'm Bryce sander this is
housewives happy hour and Kyle Richards
is here hello hello how are you I'm good
how are you good I'm happy to be here
cheers to you cheers that's such a
housewife moment yes of course
good season eight you've been doing this
for eight years now I can't believe that
what's your one word to describe this
season goal amorous crazy and dramatic
why crazy
in honor of Camille's return I wanted
you to watch back this infamous scene
okay and react to it are you ready yeah
okay let's watch this
I'm have any reason to cover my ass I
didn't say to Camille and the more I
stood up for myself just she just kept
getting madder and madder I knew I was
winning it's no come on you know the
person that remains in control is
someone that wins
she lost her cool sorry
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
such a liar Camille you know makes me
laugh about that to this day I don't get
white with people literally tweet that
to me there's means they think it's so
crazy I'm like let's make the deal so I
felt like I just said I don't know why
he would they get so crazy it doesn't
make me laugh that I was extremely
frustrated we always laugh together like
a vein bulging of my head I was oh yeah
watching that back now and knowing where
you are with Camille we would really
laugh about it in fact this season I
don't know how many times Lisa
Vanderpump said to her you're such a so
we just laugh about it now oh I always
use that you know because it was just
classic just such a like and the fact
that they can laugh because I thought
those two would never I mean they were
really like when we were in New York
that time oh lordy they were not in good
shape right I just thought I never seen
like this I love having Camille there
you know having you know just that you
know some of the original cast back just
feels good you know the fact that we are
getting along so well now I feel like
it's a good example to the rest of the
women like you guys if Camille and I can
be getting along and laughing trust me
you guys can get through this
[Music]
you
[Music]